it's a job he's spent his whole life
preparing for
one he could only inherit through the
death of his mother
to princess elizabeth heiress
presumptive to the throne a son had been
born it has been a long apprenticeship
and unlike the queen
he takes on the duty at a time in his
life when most people would retire
i believe no one has ever been better
prepared for the role of head of state
than the new king he's been heir to the
throne for so long but it's not just
that he's been very assiduous
hard-working heir to the throne i
charles prince of wales
will become your liege man of life and
limbs
[Music]
he does it for no other reason that he
was born to do it i mean no one says
uh work work 16 hours a day sir i mean
he does it because he wants to know
for the prince of wales living in a less
deferential age has had its challenges
but as air
he has brought attention to some of the
most pressing global issues
the combination of pollution and
over-consumption of finite natural
resources the urgency i think is even
greater to try and do something
about those challenges so i would ask
how these people
are going to face their grandchildren
speaking out about the environment for
more than 50 years gaining a reputation
as one of the world's most respected and
pioneering campaigners
but sometimes you think
that
do we really have to face catastrophes
and chaos before we
understand that real action needs to be
taken and the difficulty with all that
is about the time you try to take the
action it's already too late
while some people might have found his
interventions inconvenient to the
running of their particular versions of
business or or thinking actually in the
end i think the world will look back at
his career as an environmentalist and
say that it was an incredibly important
contribution at a critical time
through his prince's trust he connected
with millions of young people
his approach liberal and inclusive
especially when it came to race and
religion
he has given very important speeches
about the contribution of islam to world
civilization both in britain and in the
middle east in al-azhar university and
in saudi arabia and of course within the
jewish community we've it's been my
privilege to see him both engage
with the elderly in our old age homes
who instantly became his groupies
well briefed outspoken yet unelected
did charles as heir blur the lines
between public service and political
interference
his outspoken views on issues such as
architecture and alternative medicine
were at times controversial
his so-called black spider memos written
directly to government ministers show a
level of intervention not expected from
a royal
i think he enjoyed the controversy i
think on some occasions i complimented
him on the controversy i think he was
right about architecture at being said i
think he was right about the environment
clearly he was ahead of his time but the
point is the way he did it
and what he would do is he would
criticize people but couldn't stand
being criticized himself he would create
controversy but didn't want to listen to
people answering back how am i feeling
around his 70th birthday he set straight
how he sees his future role
charles as king now assumes a number of
key roles that will demand strong
leadership
he's head of state
defender of the faith
or as he'd rather defender of faith more
generally he's also head of the armed
forces who will pledge to serve king and
country
he's had military service he served in
the royal navy he was the captain of a
ship and he knows therefore what you
have to do if you're the boss and you're
making decisions so you can look
commanders in the eye and he remembers
what it is to look after soldiers
sailors and airmen
now as king he will receive defense
briefings all the time he's an excellent
figurehead for the armed forces
there was a time when the thought of the
prince of wales as king went against the
public mood
a failed marriage
followed by
tragedy and charles's popularity
plummeted
[Applause]
it would be eight years before he
married camilla parker-bowles the true
love of his life
they have become a close working team
and on taking on her new role as
princess consort camilla will support
her husband just as the duke of
edinburgh supported the late queen
camilla turned charles from this morose
serious unhappy man
into
into someone who lightened up who who
laughed again
after years of not really laughing very
much well it's yours now
and as a result he became a much better
prince of wales
his sense of humor and desire to connect
has softened his image in recent years
as we've seen him more as a family man a
committed husband father and grandfather
who like the rest of the country mrs
loved ones during the kovid 19 pandemic
it's terribly sad that let alone one's
friends
but um i mean fortunately you know at
least you can
speak to them on televisions and
occasionally do this sort of thing but
it isn't the same is it you want to you
really want to give people a hug
three resounding cheers for our majesty
the queen
the line of succession was secure as
signs of transition became clear
overseas tours on the queen's behalf
leading the nation in moments of
reflection
[Music]
with the support of his family he
embarks on his new role
after decades of watching
learning supporting
and developing a deep sense of service
he now takes his place
as king
you